Currently, all the list
items have the same layout.
However, we want the today
item to use a different layout
which we defined earlier in the list
item forecast today XML file.
This is where adapter item
view types will save the day.
This is a general concept for
all adapters, not just cursor adapter.
Instead of just knowing about one item
view type which yields the same layout
for all list items, the adapter can
declare multiple item view types, so
it will have different
list item layouts.
For a given row in the cursor,
the forecast adapter needs to decide
if it should be a regular list item or
a today list item.
Then it will inflate, and
bind data for the appropriate layout.
We'll jump into the forecast
adapter code now to learn how to
handle a second item view type.
Normally, in a sub class
getViewTypeCount returns one, but
we're going to override it so it returns
two for the two different layouts.
But how does it know when to
use one layout, or the other?
Well we override getItemViewType, so
that when the position in the list is
zero then we say that
it's the today view type.
Otherwise, it's
the FUTURE_DAY view type.
These two view types
are declared up above.
These are just integer
representations of the view type.
The numbering has to start at 0, because
these values cannot be greater than or
equal to getViewTypeCount.
So the possible values for us are 0 and
1, so that we know that 0 always maps
to the view_type_today, and that one
always maps to view_type_future_day.
We're going to use this information
in the new view method.
Remember that previously,
we inflated the list item forecast xml.
Now we're going to use item view type
to determine whether we should use one
layout or the other.
Fill in the TODO to
address this behavior.
LayoutID refers to resourceID
which is in the form of r
dot layout dot something.